[موسيقى
] الحبكة هنا تحظى بشعبية كبيرة ، ليس
فقط في أوزباكستان بل في جميع أنحاء العالم
، يمكن أن تكون الحبكة نفسها مثل
العديد من أنواع الحب مثل
منزل المشاهير الاحتفالي العادي مثل الشتاء
والصيف
[الموسيقى]
في ثقافتنا مهمة جدًا
مثل الانسحاب  في حد ذاته كما هو الحال عندما نقوم
بحفل الزفاف ، سيكون مثل حفل الزفاف
عندما يكون لدينا ضيوف
في منزلنا ، سنحصل عليه مثل
الزغب أيضًا وكل يوم أحد في
بعض المنازل الآن لا يزال مثل البقاء
كل يوم أحد دليل
ها هو السحر يحدث ونحن
لدينا مثل
صيغتنا السحرية zirwak إنه
لحم بقري بصل وجزر وأيضًا لدينا
زيرا وهي التوابل وأيضًا
نوع الأرز
الأنسب لبلوف أو أوش إنه ديف زيرا
لدينا  الحديد الزهر هنا
سنضيف بعض الزيت أولاً وبعد ذلك
اللحم البقري نقليها عميقًا
وبعد البصل والجزر
[موسيقى]
إذا كنت تريد مثل الألوان ،
ستضيف مثل أي شيء تريده مثل
الحمص والفواكه الجافة على سبيل المثال مثل
المشمش أو المكسرات الأخرى مثل الكاجو ،
كل أنواع الأشياء ، الأمر متروك لك ،
إنه
السحر يعني سيد أوش الذي
كرس للتو لسحب أوش ، لذلك
لدينا بشكل أساسي
مثل المنزل التقليدي مثل المنزل في المنزل مثل
كل أنواع  مثل الأطباق التي لدينا
مثل الأطباق العادية
التي تطبخها المرأة في المنزل ولكن بالنسبة
للأطباق الاحتفالية مثل
الاحتفال بالجزء
الأكبر من قدر كبير من الحب
الذي يصنعه الرجال بشكل أساسي
[الموسيقى] ،
لذا فإن ما يقدم عادة حول
الحنك  الحبكة والسلطة ولكن
السمسا هي البداية
لدينا الخبز الذي يشبه الخبز المخبوز بشكل أساسي
في
التندور ، السر هو بيلاف الرائع ولا أعتقد أنه
يوجد أي أسرار هناك كل شيء يجب أن
يكون مثل منتجات رائعة لذا يجب علينا
تحتوي على مكونات عالية الجودة
، يجب أن تكون فقط أفضل
المكونات والطعام الجيد